Карантин у Німеччині після шести тижнів суворих обмежень
послаблено ще на один рівень.
Дозволено працювати, зокрема, перукарням.
Німецькі перукарі навіть відмовилися від традиційного для них вихідного у понеділок.
Записатися до перукаря на цей чи наступний тиждень практично неможливо -
попит величезний.
Передумовою для відкриття перукарських салонів є дотримання заходів гігієни
та профілактики від коронавірусу.
В першу чергу, це захисні маски, одягнені на перукарях та клієнтах.
У масці важко дихати. Також важко розмовляти.
Проте у ній я почуваюсь безпечніше. Не лише від коронавірусу, а й від інших інфекцій.
По-друге, жодних рукостискань і дотримання відстані, наскільки це можливо.
І по-третє, обов'язкове миття у салоні волосся клієнтів.
Окрім того, працівники мусять подбати про регулярну дезінфекцію інструментів
та провітрювання.
Після півторамісячної вимушеної відпустки німецькі перукарі радо повертаються до роботи.
Адже, за приблизними оцінками, загальні втрати лише у цій сфері
сягнули близько півмільярда євро.
Однак і незвично високий попит не компенсує втрат цього року.
Багатьом салонам довелося інвестувати ще й у нове обладнання для поліпшення санітарії.
Одночасно у Німеччині відчинилися книгарні, музеї, ботанічні сади і зоопарки.
Також відтепер дозволено відвідувати дитячі майданчики.
А храми знову можуть проводити богослужіння.
На другий крок до нормалізації повсякдення нині зважилася й Італія,
яка постраждала від коронавірусу чи не найбільше в Європі.
Після жорсткого карантину, який діяв 9 тижнів, італіцям нарешті дозволено відвідати родичів.
Більше чотирьох мільйонів працівників повернулися на заводи й будмайданчики.
По всьому Риму знову залунав гуркіт будівництва.
Лячної тиші більше немає, і це підбадьорює людей після виснажливого карантину.
Щоправда, бари та навіть кіоски з морозивом наразі залишаються закритими.
А повернення громадян до місць їхнього постійного проживання
відбувається за умов обов'язкової 14-денної самоізоляції.
Пасажири мусять підходити до поліцейських та показувати їхні декларації,
де вказане місце їхньої майбутньої ізоляції.
Їм обов'язково міряють температуру.
І тоді вони мусять залишатися протягом 14 днів вдома,
повідомляючи про відсутність симптомів місцевому управлінню охорони здоров'я.
Однак через те, що в Італії влада децентралізована,
у кожному з 20 регіонів діють власні епідемічні правила.
Так, у Калабрії на півдні країни та у Венето з минулого тижня у барах і ресторанах
подають їжу і напої, а клієнтам дозволено сидіти на терасах.
Повертаються ознаки життя й у Португалії.
Тут відкрилися крамнички площею до 200 квадратних метрів.
Португальцям нарешті дозволено займатися спортом просто неба.
Розблоковано частину територій пляжів для серфінгістів.
В Іспанії, на тлі зниження кількості інфекцій та летальності від коронавірусу,
з 2 травня жителям також дозволено виходити на вулицю й займатися спортом.
Щоправда, поки лише у певні години.
Перші пом'якшення обмежень запроваджують і в Бельгії, Греції, Польщі, Монако та Ісландії.
В Австрії з цього понеділка відчинили свої двері усі школи,
але поки відвідувати уроки можна лише учням випускних класів.
Вже знято заборону для роботи всіх без винятку магазинів та закладів сфери послуг.
У середині травня зможуть відкритися кафе і ресторани,
в яких, однак, за одним столом зможуть сидіти не більше чотирьох дорослих.
Готелі зможуть відкритися з 29 травня.
Правила їхньої роботи будуть схожими на правила роботи ресторанів.
Єдиними сферами, де послаблень поки не планується,
залишаються в Австрії туризм та сфера розваг.
Прем'єр-міністр Себастіан Курц, загалом прихильник відкритості,
вже порадив австрійцям планувати проведення цьогорічної відпустки в себе на батьківщині.
У Німеччині федеральний уряд Анґели Меркель та очільники федеральних земель
6 травня розглянуть можливість чергових кроків до послаблення карантину.
Їхнє ухвалення залежатиме від успішності боротьби з коронавірусом,
підсумків першого етапу скасування низки заборон з 20 квітня
і динаміки кількості інфікованих.